I'M GOING TO CALL THIS MEETING
TO ORDER. ALL RIGHT EVERYBODY
LISTEN UP THE MEETING HAS BEEN
CALLED THE ORDER THIS IS THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SO GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME TO ANOTHER SHORT
HEARING OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TO ADHERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH OUR VICE CHAIR
SENATOR BATES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD MORNING THIS
BATES WHEN YOU HAVE IF YOU HAVE
ANY STAFF PERSON WITH YOU COULD
YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY THEM AND
NOW. I DO I HAVE BEEN.
EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT
RESTRUCTURING NEED THIS MORNING.
WELL THANK YOU- THAT IS NOTED-
SENATOR BATES AS A REMINDER
PLEASE MOVE YOUR- MUTE YOUR
PHONE OR COMPUTER THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE YOUR
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND- I NEED
POLICE SELECTOR MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSON
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN
YOU WERE DONE ONCE YOU ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR IT FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT TODAY
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR I WILL SAY
THAT AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE CODE IS SIX FIVE FOUR.
1-097-654-2897 FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITES. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE KEY OR
CUE. FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE I NEEDED AND YOU AREN'T WILL
BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AGAIN TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST USE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE ON THE
SAY THAT AGAIN. WHEN YOU BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY PLEASE MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO YOUR
TESTIMONY. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS. ALL MAINTAIN
DECORUM OBVIOUSLY DURING THESE
HEARINGS AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE MOST REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. IT'S ALSO A GOOD TIME TO
REMIND EVERYBODY PROVIDING
TESTIMONY THAT THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE SO PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL ACCESS
ASPECTS OF THE BILL THAT YOU
ARE TESTIFYING ON. WHEAT BREAD
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM REPEATING
PRIOR TESTIMONY OR RE
LITIGATING THE POLICY BEHIND
THE BILL THIS IS COMMITTEE IS
ADDRESSING JUST THE FISCAL
IMPACTS OF THAT BILL THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MATTER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF THE ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES WILL ALL TRY TO BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. SO WE HAVE ONE BILL
TODAY SB FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR
DORADO AND BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION MR SECRETARY COULD
YOU CALL THE ROLL SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. I HERE PORTANTINO
HERE SENATOR BAY. HERE BETTER
BATES HERE BRADFORD EASIER
BRADFORD HERE JONES. JONES HERE
LAYERED HERE LATER TO HEAR
WHITE HOUSE GIG HERE. CASKEY
HERE REPORT. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY MISTER RAZA WOULD YOU
PLEASE COME UP AND PRESENT S.
B. FIFTY ONE TO THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR-I THANK YOUR COMMITTEE.
YEAH. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I THANK YOU COMMITTEES-
STAFF MEMBERS. AND ALSO I
NOTICED OF TERRORISM IS
DISTRICTS AFTER SEVERAL YEARS
THE PRESSING ISSUES ON THE
CALDERON SEVEN OR- THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND
WILL PROVIDE A MEANINGFUL COST
SAVINGS FOR THE STATE. THE
MODEL THE DISEASE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ROBERT HALF
YOU. OPPORTUNITY BUILDING
WEALTH HOLE. THIS WOULD BE ONE
OF. BUT URGENT IN ORDER TO
RESOLVE THAT A LOT WITH
GOVERNOR OF SIX THAT ACTIONS
FOSTER INNOVATION S. B. AND
RAPIDLY INCREASE HOUSING ALL.
THIS IS A PATHWAY TO ONLY SHE
WELL ALLOWING FOR SPACEWALK
CONFERENCE. ALL FIVE HOUSING
ENTITIES SO MORTARBOARD
DEVELOPER GOVERNMENT NONPROFIT
AND. CRISIS ENDED. TO BEING FOR
GUARANTEED PARTNERS WERE HAVE
LOTTERY. THEY. TWELVE ONE
THOUSAND THREE OFF NINETEEN.
HEALTH CONSTANCY PRESENCE I'D
RATHER PEOPLE ON STAGE ON HOW A
LITTLE. FOR MORE THAN ONE.
MEDINA THAT'S CORRECT RIGHT
OKAY. ON HEY IF YOU WANT TO
START OVER YOU CAN OR TAPPED A
LEAVE IT UP TO YOU. IF I DON'T
HAVE TO WAIT. WE HEARD EVERY
WORD OKAY TAKE OFF FOR YOU
RIGHT. HI I JUST WANTED TO GIVE
THIS. I WANTED TO GIVE THE
SENATOR THE COURTESY BUT I DO
WE DID HEAR EVERY WORD. AND
THEN LASTLY- WITH OVER ONE
HUNDRED HOMES CURRENTLY VACANT
NEARLY HALF OF THE CALTRANS
HOMES. IN EL SERENO MANY IMPORT
CONDITION WE HAVE AN URGENT
OPPORTUNITY TO REPAIR AND
IMPROVE THE HOUSING. IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD AT NO COST TO THE
STATE. AND TO INCREASE LONG
TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING. NOT
ONLY IS A CRITICAL FOR THE
COMMUNITY IT IS FISCALLY
PRUDENT RIGHT NOW CALTRANS IS
REQUIRED TO FIX THE HOMES IN
ORDER TO SELL THE PROPERTY. AS
MOST OF THESE HOMES WOULD NOT
QUALIFY FOR HABITABILITY
STANDARDS. AGAIN CALTRANS IS
ALSO INCURRING SIGNIFICANT
COSTS. OFFER THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF FRONT OF THE HOMES
FROM BEING OCCUPIED- MR CHARTED
A WE- DO HAVE THE WITNESS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE GUESTS WE- WE- WE
DO HAVE A WITNESS- SO- YOU
CONCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. SO
I'VE WE HAVE AMY ANDERSON FROM
THE LAW OFFICE OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI ON THE
COASTLINE IS YOUR PRIMARY
SUPPORT WITNESS. MISS ANDERSON
IF YOU COULD CAN FIND YOUR
TESTIMONY TO TWO MINUTES THAT
WOULD BE GREAT AND SO I BELIEVE
WE HAVE YOU QUEUED UP. YEAH
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBER THANKS
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK THIS MORNING AGAIN I
MEANING UNDER AND I'M NOT.
COMING UP WITH- WITH MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI OF LOS ANGELES. TO
AVOID. WRONG THE CORPORATE
BECAUSE HE WON- YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA HOW PART- MEETING
AFFECT FOR AFFORDABLE. IN
CALIFORNIA HAS DETERMINED THAT
40% OF- LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
IN L. A. COUNTY. AND THE MORE
THAN HALF OF THEIR INCOME ON
HOUSING COSTS. CARNAGE ABOUT
THE ESTIMATE THAT L. A. COUNTY
NEED MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AFFORDABLE HOMES.
GENTLY REMAINS THAT FINANCIAL
BURDEN FOR THE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. I'M I'M SURE IF
YOU'RE ALL TOO AWARE OF THE
OFFICIALS- IN CALIFORNIA THAT
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE OR A
SIMPLE SOLUTION ENDING THE
STATE HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS. OR PERFECTLY FOR
EXPANDING THE COMPLIANCE
AFFORDABLE. FOR BOTH HOME. IN A
BUILDING A PART OF HOMES COMP
BY THAT EXPENSE. AND REALLY ONE
OF THE MOST AFFECTED THAT THE
CAN MAKE INCREASE MORE HOMES IS
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE ONLY AND
PROPERTY OUT THAT. ADDED TO ME
COST. AS PROPOSED BY THE ONE.
I'M LEGISLATION. ACLERIS TO
WORK OUR HOUSING CRISIS THAT
RECONFIRM THE NEED TO THE SCALP
ON HOMES OTHER PROP. GETTING
LONG TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
RESOURCES THE NEED TO MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE. AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND TO MAKE THEM OF A
AT A VERY LOW. THAT BILL. OR OR
NEW BUILDING THAT GOES ON IN
MORE FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE.
SILICATES THE TRANSITION OF THE
PROPERTIES AWAY FROM CALTRANS
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY- INTO THE
HEALTH ORGANIZATION COULD
HAPPENING IN EXPERIENCE THE
BILL AND OPERATE A HORRIBLE
HOME SO THIS IS REALLY A
FISCALLY PRUDENT. FOR THE STATE.
THAT WILL RELIEVE IT OF THE
BURDEN OF THE ON GOING ACROSS
THE SHARING KALRA ANOTHER. AND
WILL ACTIVELY INVEST AFTER
TOWARD BALDING REALLY ONE OF
OUR MOST CONTRACT TRANSITION
CRISES THANK BY THINK IT'S A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE
TO MAKE COULD DEMONSTRATE- YOU
KNOW IT COMMITMENT COMFORTABLE
HELPING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU. YEAH CONCLUDING
STATEMENT BROKE- ARE YOU DONE.
ALL RIGHT SO AMY ANDERSON IS
DONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
SANDERSON- SO ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ONE TWELVE IN
FAVOR I SEE NO ONE OUT THERE
EXCUSE ME IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
I SEE NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. AND
ONE TWELVE. THERE'S NO SUPPORT%
WITNESSES IN ONE TWELVE. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OUR LAW ONLINE
SYSTEM AT THIS POINT IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT JUST STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION- SO- TELL A MODERATOR
EITHER. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE ANYONE QUEUED UP IN
SUPPORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU DO WISH TO COMMENT AND
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE PRESS ONE ZERO. MR
CHERNOBYL IS QUEUED UP. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOW HAVE BEEN
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION SO THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IZZARD A PRIMARY
WITNESS ONLINE I DO NOT BELIEVE
IN OPPOSITION SO THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM IN OPPOSITION AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN OPPOSITION. SO MR
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THE WITNESSES AND THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND I'LL
LET THE FIRST ONE YOU QUEUE UP
HAVE A AS MUCH AS TWO MINUTES
AND THEN THEREAFTER IT WILL BE-
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
SO- EVERS THE LUCK OF THE DRAW
GETS THE FIRST COMMENT IF
THERE'S ANYBODY THERE. IN
OPPOSITION. AND AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS. ONE ZERO. BUT WE DO HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE SHOWING UP AT
THIS MOMENT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR.
MISTER CHAIR WE WILL NOW
GO TO LINE TWELVE LINE TWELVE
YOUR MIND IS OPEN. RIGHT MENTAL
CONTACT WITH A MAN- THE PERSON
THAT IS IN CONSTANT- AND BIAMBY
THE GENDER OF GRAVY HELLO OF
OPPOSITION AT THE THIRTY ONE
BUT- UNLIKE ARE THAT NO THE OF
EXISTING TENANTS TO THAT HAPPEN
ALL YOU SPEAK AT YOU SPEAK UP A
LITTLE BIT PLEASE SPEAK INTO
THE SPEAK AND REMARKS WE CAN
HEAR YOU. CLEARLY EVERY BETTER
NOW HELLO BETTER. OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER- SO MY MANAGER'S
NOTE THERE SHOULD BE NO
DIFFERENCE OF THE TENANTS ARE
LOOKING AND SHOULD BE IN GOOD
STANDING CONTINUE TO ALLOW OUT
THERE OUR RESIDENTS FORM COSTS
SUCH AS THE ALTOONA COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST WHICH HAS INTERESTS
IN THE HOME. GIVE THE EXISTING
TENANTS ABSOLUTE. TO BRIDGE
OVER ARE YOU AND OTHER. DO NOT
ALLOW NON. AFTER EASTER BUNDLE
MORE PROPERTIES. AND I. THE
BILLDISCRIMINATE AGAINST OUT
THREE ARRESTS- BERMAN SHOULD
APPLY. THE WHOLE QUARTER OR BE
WITH LONG- ANOTHER MY MAIN
OPPOSITION BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE- ARE INTERESTED IN
DANCE- INDIA- THAT NEED BE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION THAT
HAVE YOU KNOW PLANS THAT- BUT
ALSO AND OTHER PEOPLE WHO.
CONTINUE TO IGNORE- EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE TRYING TO ACTUALLY HELP
THE PEOPLE WE ARE THE PEOPLE
TRYING TO HELP THE PEOPLE. SO
THE OTHER THINGS THAT NEED TO
BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION NOW
THE DOCTOR HAS CONTINUED. FOR
MONTHS. TAKE NORMALLY EVEN
THOUGH- AND RECLAIMER. I'M ALSO
NOW. YOU CAN TRY TO YOU KNOW
YOU CAN JUST. READ ABOUT THE
PROBLEMS NOT EVEN YOU KNOW THEN
SHE REFUSES TO THE OUT OF THE-
THAT. THE PRODUCT VEHICLE.
FACEBOOK THANK YOU SO. TO WILL
BE TO NAME ORGANISE AND
POSITION. SO MR MY IF YOU COULD
CAN TO QUEUE UP FOLKS YOU. SIX
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE WILL
NOW GO TO MIND KIND PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TURN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY DOCTOR CLIENTS
THOMAS WILLIAMS LA THIRTY TWO
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL DIRECTOR
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NOW
GO TO LINE. SEVEN YES HM I'M A
MEMBER WITH EAST YARDAGE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND I AM
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AT.
THANGAL NOW GO TO LINE.
FOURTEEN YEAH MY NAME IS NOT
EVEN ACTUAR- I WORK WITH THE
EASTSIDE CAFE IN TOWSON ON TV.
AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WHY.
THIRTEEN YEAH I'M A COOK AND
I'M NOT A MEMBER OF A SPECIFIC
ORGANIZATION BUT I LOOKED INTO
THAT THE FIFTY ONE AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THAT THE BILL. MARK.
LINE. ELEVEN YEAH COMMITTEE
IVERSEN PHD CALTRANS TEN
INTERESTED IN A AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL SB FIFTY ONE. WINE.
TWENTY FOUR. YES THANK YOU THIS
IS BRIAN DAHLE- PASADENA
TENANTS UNION AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ORGANIZATION
TENANTS TOGETHER- IN OPPOSITION.
LINE. TWENTY SIX. WHAT ARE THE
NUMBERS WE NEED TO FLOATERS SO
THERE ARE CONSTANTINOPLE IS TO
BE. THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
THE NOT A. LINE. TWENTY FIVE.
MY TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
TWENTY ONE. MY TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THERE MY NAME
IS UNLAWFUL ORDERS MY FAMILY
AND I HAVE BEEN TENANTS FOR THE
LAST TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
TRANSCANADA MCCARTY UNITED
CALTRANS CURRENT FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS WHEN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU YOU.
WINE CHRISTINE. HI MY NAME IS
ALLISON BAGS I'M A HOMEOWNER IN
EL SERENO AND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THAT THE FIFTY ONE.
THE LINE. SEVENTEEN LOTUS BACK
SOUTH PASADENA- PHD- MEMBER OF
UNITED CALTRANS TENANT STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL IT DISCRIMINATES
AND ELIMINATE THE RIGHT TO
CORPS. SHOULD APPLY IF IT'S SO
GOOD IT SHOULD APPLY TO ALL
RIGHT DO YOU CITIES I WANT TO
ASK PORTANTINO SENATOR
PORTANTINO WHY HE DOESN'T HAVE
THAT BUILT TO APPLY TO SOUTH
PASADENA AND PASADENA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PLEASE AT THIS POINT
WE'RE LIMITING OUR COMMENTS THE
NAME ORGANIZATION. AND POSITION
SO THANK YOU. BLIND COOLEY. TO
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
CONGRESS FOR THREE YEARS I'M
WITH THE RECLAIMING AND
REBUILDING OUR COMMUNITIES AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIFTY ONE.
WE. AND I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
LINE TWENTY FIVE TO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO TOGETHER AGAIN IF
THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL MY
TWENTY FIVE IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THOROUGH. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COULD YOU JUST CHECK ONE
TIME MORE TO MAKE SURE WE'VE
HEARD FROM EVERYBODY WHO HAS.
QUEUED UP TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
NOT MISSING ANYBODY. I'M FOR OR
AGAINST. MISTER CHAIR WE DO
HAVE ADDITIONAL OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE LINING UP BEGAN TO SPEAK
I'M GONNA CALL ON LINE TWENTY
FIVE MY TWENTY FIVE YEAR ONE IS
OPEN. I HAVE BEEN AFTER ME. HI
THIS IS SANDRA I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO ANTI ON. FIFTY
ONE. NOW GO TO LINE THIRTY WELL
WHAT. HELLO- LEADER ME BUT ONE
FIVE YES PLEASE YES PLEASE YES
SIR STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
PREDICAMENT THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS TO GO GARCIA ON MY CANON-
CALTRANS TENANTS IN EL SERENO
I'VE BEEN LIVING HERE FOR LIKE.
OVER THIRTY YEARS AND- I STAND
OPPOSED AS WELL AS OTHER
RESIDENTS STAND OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU- I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW. THANK YOU SIR
WERE. SIR AT THIS POINT IN THE
HEARING WE'RE JUST TAKING YOUR
POSITION WE'VE ALREADY HAD THE
TESTIMONY ON THE MERITS OF THE
BILL SO I APOLOGIZE BUT THAT'S
THE POLICY. OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT PERSON. THANK YOU FOR
EXPRESSING YOUR OPPOSITION.
PLYING. TWENTY SEVEN. HI MY
NAME IS YOU HAVE TO MAKE MONEY
THAT MANADA PROBLEM HERE- NO
OFFICIAL ORGANIZATION AND I
OPPOSE SB FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU.
LINE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA MOP THE FLOORS AND I
WON IT- LET THE PEOPLE KNOW
THAT I DISAGREE AND THEREFORE
OPPOSE SB FIFTY ONE I LIVE IN
SOUTH PASADENA ON THE BORDER OF
SERENO AND HAS A LOT OF FRIENDS
AND FAMILY AND TENANTS AND ALSO
YOU KNOW. AND THIS BILL COOLEY
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST US YOU
KNOW TENANTS THANK YOU IT WAS.
SO GOOD THE QUESTION. THANK YOU.
MR WE HAVE BUT ONCE AGAIN WE
HAVE NO WINNING TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU AND JUST SO THE
FOLKS OUT THERE UNDERSTAND WE
HAD TAKE A PRIMARY WITNESS AND
WE GIVE THEM TIME TO MAKE THEIR
ARGUMENTS AND THEN THE
SUBSEQUENT. TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO NAME OCCUPATION OR
SHE MAY ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION SO I APOLOGIZE THAT
WE- CUT SOME FOLKS OFF BUT
THAT'S THE POLICY THAT THE
SUBSEQUENT- TESTIMONIES JUST IS
LIMITED. YES AND ANYBODY WHO-
THE COMMITTEE IS TAKING WRITTEN
COMMENTS SO IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
FURTHER- PUBLIC RECORDS ON YOUR
POSITION WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS AND PUT
THOSE INTO THE RECORD. AGAIN
THAT'S PART OF THE PROCESS
SINCE WE'VE GONE TO PREVENT.
CANCER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE YOUR PARTICIPATION IN
YOUR INTEREST IN THIS BILL. I
ALSO WANTED TO LET FOLKS KNOW
THAT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL.
AND WILL NOT BE PARTICIPATING
TODAY SO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SHOULD KNOW THAT. AND THEN
WE'LL TAKE THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS MANY
MEMBERS HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT FOR THE AUTHOR. MISTER
Y. CASKEY I WAS WONDERING I'M-
SORRY TO FINANCES IN HERE DO WE
KNOW IF. IF THE STATE HIGHWAY
COUNTY EVER RECEIVED MONEY FROM
THIS PASADENA EL SERENO AREA ON
THE SALE OF SURPLUS PROPERTY
AND IN THE PRESUMPTION WOULD
BE. IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE NOT
GETTING ANY MONEY THEN YOU
WOULDN'T BE AND THE RIBBON
ROADS THAT COULD BE BUILT AND
THERE'S NO NEED FOR THAT.
RECYCLING OF THE MONEY FROM
THIS X. THE SURPLUS SALE TO GO
INTO THE- THE CONSTRUCTION SO I
GUESS THAT'S MY QUESTION. I'M
MISTRAS ROCKET FROM TAKE THAT
YES MONEY DOES GO INTO THE
ACCOUNT AND SOME OF THE AND THE
CITIES WITHIN THE CORRIDOR.
HAVE USE THAT MONEY AND PLAN TO
USE THAT MONEY SO THAT COUNT IS
ACTIVE RIGHT. RIGHT BUT JIM AND
SUBSEQUENT SOME THERE WILL BE
LOCAL ROAD IMPROVEMENTS AND
LOCAL- PROJECTS THAT WILL BE
FUNDED FROM THAT ACCOUNT NOT
THE FREEWAY ITSELF IS DEAD BUT-
OKAY LOCAL PROJECTS AND
PRESENT. ASSEMBLY AT THE AT THE
SALE OF THE LAST PROPERTY IN
THE DISPEL THAT. THAT BY HAVING
YOU OF FUNDS WILL STOP BECAUSE
THERE WILL BE NO SURPLUS
PROPERTY OR FEDERAL OFFICIALS
RIGHT WRECKED- BUT ALSO MISTER
ROGER FIVE MAY THE ONE POT I'M
ANOTHER POSITIVE OF SELLING THE
HOUSES. IS CURRENTLY THEY'RE
NOT GENERATING LOCAL SALES TAX
FOR THE COMMUNITY SO. LONG TERM
ONCE THOSE PROPERTIES ARE IN
PRIVATE HANDS WILL BE
GENERATING SALES TAX TO FOUR.
L. A. ALHAMBRA SOUTH PASS AND
PASADENA
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR
MISTER ROGERS YES MISTER JONES.
THANK YOU SIR DRAWS I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT GETTING CALTRANS OUT OF
THE HOME OWNERSHIP AND RENTAL
BUSINESS- WE HAD A SIMILAR
SITUATION IN MY DISTRICT
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND- AS SOON
AS THESE PROPERTIES WERE SOLD
TO PRIVATE. PROPERTY THE
NEIGHBORHOODS IMMEDIATELY. SO I
DO HAVE SOME FISCAL CONCERNS-
ONE OUR STAFF REACHED OUT TO
CALTRANS TO TRY TO FIND. THE
SALES PRICE OF THE DIFFERENT
PROPERTIES AND- CALTRANS WAS
UNABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION. SO I'M I'M
WONDERING YOU KNOW WHY. LET ME
THEY NEED THEY SHOULD KNOW WHAT
THE ORIGINAL SALES PRICE WAS
AND IT WAS I AM PART OF MY
CONCERN ON THAT IS YOU KNOW
THESE ARE FIFTY YEAR OLD.
PROPERTIES YOU KNOW IT'S VERY
LIKELY THAT FIFTY YEARS AGO A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME IN THIS AREA
SOLD FOR YOU KNOW SIX TO TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THAT TODAY
WOULD BE WORTH. AND I'M
GUESSING I'M NOT THAT FAMILIAR
WITH IT YOU KNOW AT LEAST THE
MEDIAN PRICE AROUND SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND. SO WHY NOT.
WHY NOT GET THE- APPRAISAL AND
SELL IT AT MARKET RATE. IF I
CAN- BASICALLY THEY WILL BE
SOLD AT EITHER MARKET OR-
AFFORDABLE- EXCEPT FOR THE
HOUSING ENTITIES OR THE LOCAL
YOU KNOW CITY OR COUNTY IF THEY
WANT TO COMMIT TO THE GUARANTEE
OF LONG TERM AFFORDABILITY
FIFTY FIVE YEARS THOSE ARE THE
ONES WHO ARE GOING TO GET IT
OUT TO REGIONAL ACQUISITION
PRICE SO IT'S A IT'S A GIVE AND
TAKE. THEY'LL BE ABLE TO GET IT
AT A MUCH REDUCED RATE BECAUSE
LAND IS SO EXPENSIVE AND
PRODUCING AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
THEY'LL GET IT AT THE ORIGINAL
ACQUISITION AND THEN THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO INVEST TO REPAIR THE
REMODEL THEM AND MAKE THEM LONG
TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IT'S
IN THE ORIGINAL ACQUISITION
PRICES NOT FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNERS IS GOING TO BE A
GUARANTEE OF- THIS LONG TERM
AFFORDABILITY SO IF I
UNDERSTAND YOUR ANSWERS ON THE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES IT WILL BE
SOLD FOR MARKET YOU STILL BE
SOLD AT A MARKET RATE. WELL
EITHER MARKET OR FOR DOUBLE
DEPENDING ON THE TENANT AND
OKAY AND THERE LOW INCOME YES
IF YOU WANT ME TO ADD A LITTLE
BIT- SO THERE'S A WHOLE OUTLINE
OF PRIORITIES AND ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE LONG TERM TENANTS WHO
HAVE BEEN IN THERE FOR SOME OF
THEM THIRTY PLUS YEARS- THERE'S
ALL INCOME THRESHOLD. AND SO
THOSE TENANTS WHO WILL BUY
THEIR HOUSES AT LESS THAN
AFFORDABLE RATE THE STATE WILL
MAINTAIN AN INTEREST IN THE
EQUITY- SO UNDER THE RIVER TO
BILL AND UNDER A CALLALOO BILL
THERE'S A WHOLE DEFINITION OF
HOW THAT IS SPLIT. AND SO THE
STATE CAN BE MADE WHOLE IN
THOSE SO THE LONG STANDING
TENANTS WHO MEET THE INCOME
ELIGIBILITY CAN BITE AT LESS
THAN MARKET RATE BUT THE STAFF
AT WHICH TIME IT GETS SOLD THAT
EQUITY PIECE TO BE THE DELTA
BETWEEN MARKET RATE AND THE
DISCOUNT RATE THE STATE STILL
HAS THAT INTEREST. IN THAT-
BACK FROM A CARE BILL THAT WAS
PUT AND- ALSO THE RIVER HE
BUILT. THE SEVENTIES. ALL OF
THAT IS TO FIND- THE ONLY WAY
THEY CAN DO THAT IS IF AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION CORRECT
THAT'S WHAT MISTER ROGERS DOING
IN HER VILLAGE AND IF THEY HAVE
A COVENANT THAT THOSE. UNITS
STAY AFFORDABLE FOR WHICH IT
FIFTY YEARS FIFTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIFTY FIVE YEARS OR SO THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
MISTER ROGERS DOING IN. HER
DISTRICT VERSUS THE REST OF THE
CORRIDORS JUST THAT ONE PIECE.
ON THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMPONENT BUT WAS YOUR OFFICE
ABLE TO GET ANY OF THOSE
NUMBERS FROM CALTRANS THAT YOU
COULD SHARE WITH THE REST OF
US. AND ALSO IN ADDITION TO
THAT HOW MANY ATMS ARE INVOLVED
I MEAN. PIECES OF PROPERTY-
PART OF THIS. WELL I KNOW THE
NUMBER OF. PROPERTIES WE
DIDN'T- WE CAN GET FOR YOU
BEING. A PROPERTY PER PROPERTY
WHAT THE- BY WOULD THAT THEY
WOULD BE SOLD CALTRANS HAS AN
EXCEL SPREADSHEET SOMEWHERE
THAT SAYS A. P. N. NUMBER BLAH
BLAH BLAH ORIGINALLY SOLD FOR
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS OR-
OR WHATEVER I DON'T HAVE THAT
HERE BUT OKAY. WE GET IT WE CAN
I'M SURE BETWEEN MR ASO IN MY
OFFICEWE COULD FIND THAT FOR
YOU AND GET THAT TO YOU. I MEAN
I THINK THAT WOULD BE GOOD
INFORMATION FISCAL INFORMATION
FOR THE- THIS COMMITTEE TO
HAVE- THERE'S A THERE'S A TOTAL
OF TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR OF
PROPERTIES IN THE EL SERENO LOS
ANGELES AREA IT'S A MIX OF
OCCUPIED SINGLE AND MULTI
FAMILY AND UNOCCUPIED IT IS
UNBELIEVABLE TO ME THAT WE HAVE
A HUNDRED. VACANT HOMES IN LA-
I MEAN THAT IS JUST A CRIME I
DON'T SEE CRIMINAL THAT ALMOST
CRIMINAL- SO I'M GONNA LAY OFF
THE BILL TODAY AND GET THOSE
ANSWERS BUT HOPEFULLY I- MILIK
CITED LEAKS SUPPORTED ON THE
FLOOR. WELL SOME PEOPLE LIKE
CARTER HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR MANY MANY MANY YEARS
DECADES AND DECADES SO WE'RE
GLAD- THAT WE'RE FINALLY ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH WITH THESE
PROPERTIES YEAH I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THE DOLLARS AND SENSE
MAKES SENSE. FOR OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MISTER
BRADFORD YEAH I TO HAVE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY THOSE CURRENT TENANT AND IF.
THE GOAL IS TO KEEP FOLKS
HOLLISTER I AM REALLY I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LEVEL
OPPOSITION TO THOSE FOLKS WHO
STATE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN THERE
FOR TWENTY PLUS IS SOME STATED
THIRTY TWO YEARS AND THESE
PROPERTIES AND IF THIS IS SUCH
A GREAT IDEA WHY DOES IT NOT
AFFECT ENTIRE CORRIDOR THAT THE
CALTRANS ONLY'S PROPERTIES FOR.
OVER PROBABLY FIFTY YEARS SHOWN
JUST CURIOUS ABOUT THAT AND-
JUST HOW ARE THOSE TENANTS
RIGHT NOW WHO WERE THERE AND-
GOING TO BE PROTECTED AT. I'M
SORRY I THINK I THINK I HEARD
TWO TWO QUESTIONS ONE IS- THE
CURRENT TENANTS. TO RENO. BUT
THE CONDITIONS AND THE ON THE
NEEDS I THINK ARE PARTICULARLY
DIFFERENT IN THE L. SERENO AREA
FROM PASADENA AND SOUTH
PASADENA ALSO. WELL FOR SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENCE MORE HISTORIC
THORTON IS HIS STORY HOMES
THERE'S A LOT LESS OF
PROPERTIES IT'S JUST TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES IN THE REST OF THE
CORRIDOR PASADENA SOUTH
PASADENA IS QUITE DIFFERENT
FROM. THE WAY THE WHOLE THE
HOUSING IN THE OTHER IN EL
SERENO AND ALLEY CITY PARK SO
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE BEST IF
WE- ARE FOCUSED ON WHAT THE
NEEDS HAVE BEEN. A LOT MORE ON
OCCUPIED A LOT MORE HOT HOUSING
THAT NEEDS WORK- AND SO ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT CONDITIONS THAT
IS TO THINK THIS IS BETTER TO
FOCUS BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
MAJOR ISSUES HAVE BEEN IS IN
THE EL SERENO PART OF THE
CORRIDOR. WE REALLY WANT TO
FOCUS IN TWO MOVIES PROPERTIES
FORWARD AND THERE AGAIN- THE
CHAIRS AS REPRESENTATIVE OF
THAT AREA. KNOWS THAT THERE ARE
DISTINCTIONS THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
MOE FORWARD WITH AFFORDABILITY
AND ALSO SELLING IT TO THE
CURRENT TENANTS SO THE CURRENT
TENANTS WILL BE ABLE TO BUY IF
THEY WANT IF THEY DON'T WANT.
YOU'LL STAY THERE NOT GOING TO
BE EVICTED ON YOU KNOW THERE'S
INCOME LEVELS ARE THAT HAVE TO
BE MET OF FOR AFFORDABILITY I
THINK IT WAS YOU- CENTER
PORTANTINO THAT. MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAD THE AFFORDABLE RENTERS
PROGRAM THAT WAS EXTENDED THERE
BECAUSE THERE WAS A SUNSET ON
IT. SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING ONE IS TO SUPPORT
OUR HOMEOWNERSHIP IN THIS
COMMUNITY THOSE WHO ARE TENANTS
AND STAY THERE AND BUY THEM IF
THEY WISH. IF THEY CAN'T OR-
AND FOR THOSE BACON PROPERTIES
LET'S AND DOES A AND- LET'S PUT
THE INTO THE HANDS OF. YOU KNOW
PROFESSIONAL OF A PROFESSIONAL
HOUSING DEVELOPERS- ENTITIES
THAT KNOW HOW TO BRING IT UP TO
PAR AND THEN THEY CAN. MAKE
THIS LONG TERM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING M. MR FOR ME I'M JUST
OVER HERE MISTER BRADFORD THERE
IS A PROCESS IN PLACE. FOR
SELLING THE HOUSES THAT
RESPECTS THE INCOME. LEVELS OF
THE LONG STANDING TENANTS SO
JUST BECAUSE THIS BILLS
SPECIFIC EL SERENO DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THE OTHER PARTS OF THE
DISTRICT AREN'T GOVERNED BY
PRIOR LEGISLATION INDISPOSITION
AND CALTRANS. THOUGH NOT MOVING
AS FAST AS ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
IS SELLING THOSE HOMES
ACCORDING TO THAT- PRIOR
LEGISLATION. AND SO- THAT THAT
I MEAN THAT'S JUST FACTUAL IN
IN HOW YOU KNOW IT'S BEING DONE
AND AS I EXPLAINED MISTER
JONES. THOSE LONGSTANDING
TENDED TO GET TO BUY IT AT A
DISCOUNTED RATE THERE'S
PROVISIONS BOTH TO PROTECT
THOSE TENANTS IF THEY'RE IN THE
FORM OF A HOUSING PROGRAM AS
WELL AS THE STATE'S. INTEREST
IN THOSE PROJECTS BUT WOOD
MISTER ROGERS DOING IN HER
SECOND. SECTION IS TWEAKING
THAT SLIGHTLY IN RELATION TO
THE TO THE NON PROFITS THAT'S
THE DIFFERENT COMPONENT BETWEEN
THE REST OF THE DISTRICT. AND
THE EL SERENO PEACE AND SO.
THAT THAT'S THE- THAT'S THE
MAJOR DIFFERENCE. BUT THE OTHER
STILL IS GOVERNED ALL OF THE-
ELIGIBILITY THE LONGSTANDING
PROTECTIONS. AND THE PROCESSES
THAT GO BACK TO DAVID ROBERTI
AND THEN WORKED WEEK PROBABLY
SIX TIMES SINCE THEN THE OTHER
THING THAT'S GOING ON IS
CALTRANS. I BELIEVE WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR THE OVERALL
REGULATIONS THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSEDTO DRAFT BASED ON THAT
LEGISLATION AND SO. THAT'S PART
OF WHAT. THE AMOUNT OF MY
DISTRICT WANTS TO SEE WHAT
THOSE REGULATIONS ARE BEFORE WE
GO DOWN CHANGING ANY OF THE
PROCESSES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE THE LATE SEVENTIES
AND TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
SINCE THEN. BUT MISTER ROGER
HAS A UNIQUE SITUATION IN HER
DISTRICT THAT SHE'S SHE'S DOING
AND SO I'LL MAKE MY COMMENT IF
I MAY MISAPPROPRIATE STRUCTURE
MR. I MOVE THE BILL WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. MISTER
ROGERS I'M GONNA GO TO YOUR
CLOTHES BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
REAL QUICK- YOU KNOW I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN A PROPONENT THAT
YOU KNOW SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS YOU KNOW. DEALING WITH
THEIR OWN DISTRICT ISSUES
SHOULD BE GIVEN DEFERENCE TO IT
TO ME IT'S THE WAY THIS HOUSE
USED TO FUNCTION. IN IN THE
OLDEN DAYS SO I APPRECIATE YOU
RESPECTING THAT PROCESS THIS IS
A DISTRICT TO ME THIS IS A
DISTRICT SPECIFIC BILL AND SO
THAT'S WHY I'M GIVING
DIFFERENCE TO IT AND- EXPECTED
WHEN IT COMES BACK TO STAY THAT
WAY- AND AGAIN AS I JUST
EXPLAINED YOU KNOW THE ALHAMBRA
WE ALSO HAVE TO RESPECT HIS
RUBIO HAMMERS PART BY PART. OF
THE DISTRICT- HAVE A PROCESS IN
PLACE AND WE WILL BE LOOKING AT
THAT AS IT UNFOLDED WHEN THOSE
REGULATIONS COME OUT FROM
CALTRANS AND SO WE'LL SEE HOW
WE CAN IMPROVE. ON THAT IN IN
MY PART OF THE DISTRICT AND SO
WITH THAT IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
A BRIEF CLOSE. WILL TAKE ABOUT
AFTER THAT. SO AGAIN- WE
INTRODUCE AS BEFORE. ONE TO
BRING MORE LONG TERM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TELL SERENO AND DEVELOP
THIS LONG TERM SOLUTION. FOR
THOSE RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES.
AGAIN SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN
SITTING VACANT AND IN
DISRESPECTFUL. AND YEARS. AND
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
WORST HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY SO. WILL SECURE
THE SALE OF THESE HOUSES TO LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME TENANTS. OR
CONVERT THEM INTO LONG TERM
AFFORDABLE RENTERS. RENTALS IF
THE TENANTS ARE NOT INTERESTED
OR IF THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO BUY
THE HOME. FACILITATE THE REPAIR
OF THE EXISTING HOMES AND
FINALLY. ALLOW CALTRANS TO GET
OUT OF THE BUSINESS OF RENTING
HOMES SOLD. THERE IS AN URGENT
DEMAND FROM OUR COMMUNITY TO.
SOLVE THIS- AND IT'S ABOUT
GIVING ALSO DENTAL. THE LONG
OVERDUE ATTENTION THAT THAT
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY DESERVES
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER RAZA
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION TO
DISPATCH REFERRED THE BILL TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. SO MR
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THROUGH OUR- BILLERS
SB FIFTY ONE THE MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO HI
SENATOR BATES. ALL RIGHT- BATES
BY. CENTER BRADFORD. SENATOR
JONES. CENTER LAYERED HI BLARED
HI SIR MY CASKEY- HI THERE MY
CASKEY ARE BEFORE BILLS FOR
VOTED IS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
ROGERS AND WITH THAT THAT IS
THE AGENDA THAT THE END OF OUR
AGENDA I WILL. IN THIS MEETING
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
AND I THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED